[Music]
hello my name is
david bieber and i investigate
collective behavior and collective
intelligence
here at humboldt university yeah at the
moment we're at the
campus north in mitte at humboldt
university
we're here in the facilities of the
department of biology and ecology of
fish
here we investigate with the robofish
collective behavior of
fish swarms and we try to get
the rules and the mechanisms how swarms
how groups
really function with that robofish
and then we hope to apply our knowledge
also to other animals or even to humans
or to autonomously driving cars and
drones
we see here our so called robofish
which is an artificial build fish
that is aimed to interact with light
fish
and uh basically this robot consists of
two units the first unit is a fish-like
uh fish dummy a replica of a of a live
fish that we made by
3d printing and then we color it we
attach little glass eyes
on that dummy fish
and because we know or we found out that
these glass eyes really attract the live
fish
so they really accept this kind of
artificial fish as a con specific
and the second part is below this
aquarium
it's a robot unit that is basically yeah
a small card that we can steer with
a wireless lan and so uh
both parts are coupled with magnets so
at the food of this little fish there
are two magnets and on top of the robot
unit they are also a magnet
so we can steer and drag
this fish dummy through the tank and so
really control it as we want
and by having several cameras filming
the whole setup
we can give the robot the coordinates of
the live fish and then let the robot
interact with the live fish in real time
so it's autonomously
driving or swimming through the tank and
so we can test
how live fish react to different
robots that yeah behave in different
ways
yeah the first prototypes of this kind
of uh
yeah robofish they were produced in the
uk
my my boss had an
first idea on that and they tried it
with a different species with
the stickleback and
they can't use this automatic or
integrated behavior but it was
the first time they really started to
use these kind of dummy fish
that were uh driven by a robotic air
unit
to interact with live fish and then yeah
here in berlin
my boss and i we we started in
collaborating with
uh robotic engineers from the pre
university to really build
a even smaller model of the robofish
that is able to
freely interact with guppies with
mollies with other tropical fish that
are more easy to keep
in a laboratory and so step by step we
uh yeah
added things we refined the appearance
of the dummy
and yeah for example we we first started
by
painting the eyes on the dummy and the
fish didn't react
very well to that so they didn't accept
this kind of a dummy fish as a corn
specific
and then the idea was to to use a teddy
bear glass eyes
to put on the dummy and that worked so
we can put this
dummy fish inside a normal aquarium and
some of the males will start courting
this dummy so they really believe it's a
con specific
yeah it is for to to investigate
collective behavior and
collective movement behavior normally we
we can just observe huge groups or
aggregates of
animals like birds or fish or some
uh yeah zebra herds but um
we can't really manipulate the rules how
these individuals interact
we have some ideas how these rules are
but we can't really test because to test
the rules
we have to manipulate what uh the
animals really do
inside these swarms these groups
and the robot we can integrate an
individual inside these groups these
swarms
and then manipulate the rules how the
robot interacts with its neighbors
and so we can test which rules are
really important which rules
are not so important and which rules we
may have missed in our
theoretical considerations about how a
swarm is
functioning
[Music]
i mean the idea to use artificial
animals is old so even in the beginning
of
this field the ethology looking at a
behavior of animals people use some
artifacts or dummies to
stimulate live animals and with
the even better uh robotic techniques at
the moment
we saw that this is a perfect um yeah
field where we can go in and
use these new kinds of electronics
and techniques to to really bring that
field forward
and integrate such a yeah fish-like
robot into a live swarm
[Music]
whenever humans interact non-verbally
so whenever people meet and don't talk
to each other
they use similar rules that we can find
in these fish swarms we can find in uh
yeah
flocking birds or in uh other mammals in
big uh
swarms the same very same rules and they
are based on the distances
among the individuals so one of these
rules is to
um yeah go wherever you see a neighbor
individual
and when this neighboring individual is
within an optimal zone around you
you align with it then you move into the
same direction
and when it's coming too close you avoid
this individual by moving away from it
and these three simple rules by
attracting
so swimming towards or moving towards
the con specific neighbor
then aligning with it when it's in the
optimal distance and
avoiding it so moving away from it when
it's coming too close these
three simple rules they also work with
humans that was tested
also with people from our lab renting a
big
gym and inviting many people to
participate
and they were given these rules and uh
yeah they really acted as a swarm and
then we can also uh yeah
introduce leaders into these uh kind of
uh swarms
by giving some in the woodworks
information where to move
and then when all the others follow
these rules so
align with the neighbors that are around
me
and follow them then a leader that moves
to a certain
direction will keep all the others
following him
i mean we are in some situations that
simple
not in all situations but in many
situations for example when you go to a
stadium or do a
music concert and you don't know your
neighbors you don't talk to them
but you follow where they walk you
follow where they move
and then you apply very similar rules so
we all know this uh this minimum
distance that we want to keep to others
uh that it's not offending uh to us and
this is very similar to the avoidance
rules that
animals have in their swarms when others
come too close
and this is uh yeah so in fact we use
very similar distance based rules
for our interaction and another um
thing that we can learn from these swarm
experiments here with the robot
and the live fish is how information is
spreading
through big swarms big schools big
groups
and this is very similar then when one
fish for example
um yeah sees a predator recognize that
there is a predator
it will move away from that predator in
a specific way
in a very fast way so that indicates
there is something and all the others
react to that so they don't see the
predators themselves but they have to
react
to the uh behavior of their con specific
and then this information that there is
a predator will spread through the whole
group
and we can see similar things when we
look at the social media where
some tweets spread in very short time
around the globe
and it's the same rules that apply here
so the advantage of using uh fish and
small sized fish is that we can have
them in the laboratory
at a high density so we can really
simulate their swarming behavior in the
laboratory
which is not possible when you uh yeah
think about birds or even larger mammals
you always have to go
into the wild and observe them and then
your um
ability to manipulate them in a way that
you can test several
of your hypothesis is very limited so
here we can
manipulate a lot we can test a lot of
theories by still having them
in their natural density in their
natural group size
which is not possible with bigger
animals and with animals that need
more specific habitats or care yeah so
the
the normal work life here is uh
basically that
we decide uh on on the ideas that we
want to test on our hypothesis
beforehand
and then we try to design experiments so
we asked what predictions
do uh relate to that hypothesis
and then we try to design experiments
that can
specifically test these predictions and
then we look
okay can we use the robot for that or do
we have to observe live
groups or do we have yeah the right
cameras the right software
to investigate the group behavior then
when that is all decided then we go
and ask for the permissions to do the
experiments
and then we start doing the experiments
here in the lab and it's most often it's
a it's a
bout of experimental work then about of
time that you spend
analyzing uh your videos your
observations
your data and then you see okay maybe
that worked out uh pretty well then you
try to
publish that as a result or you go back
to the lab which is most
common procedure and you refine
something and then try it again
so to always have a continuous
improvement of your
experiments that you then can really
answer your questions
this laboratory is part of the
excellence cluster science of
intelligence which is located at the
technical university
the tu and free university and as well
the humboldt university
but we also cooperate with the leibniz
institute for freshwater ecology and
inland fisheries
yeah so the limits with this kind of
experiments
is for sure that we cannot create
a really natural environment for that as
you see here the tank is uh yeah
almost empty so we can't uh allow the
fish to interact with
a lot of structures here because the
robot will yeah
can't uh really swim around them or will
culidate uh
with these structures then so we have to
have a very clean tank
and that is yeah for sure not a
mirroring that what
the animals have in nature so that's why
we always try to complement our research
here in the lab
also with research in the wild so we
regularly go
to for example south america to middle
america central america where these
animals live
and observe them in the wild we take big
cameras with us we observe their
grouping behavior
and then we try to connect both things
so
here on the left we can get the
mechanisms how
something works and then in the wild we
look why do they do it and how do they
do it in a larger scale
and this is something we we also yeah
try to do in all the student work here
to have a a laboratory
compartment or computer component of the
work
and a field-based component of the work
[Music]
the excellence cluster science of
intelligence
has the aim to understand intelligent
behavior
at many different levels of organization
in animals in humans but also in
artificial agents like drones or
cars or robotic swarms
and our idea is that one has to have
always an analytic part where you
analyze what you see
and what you do and the synthetic part
where you put
your knowledge that you observed or that
you got from your observations
into build agent
and the synthetic part and this analytic
part they're in all projects of the
science
of intelligence cluster are merged so we
always have a component that
involves building off synthetic agents
like the robotic fish
and we have parts of analytic
base on an analytic base that
really analyzes what you see what rules
apply
and these uh combination of the two
parts the synthetic side
and the analytic side it really makes
this cluster special
and we think that this is a good way to
really get
to know what is individual intelligence
what is social intelligence and what is
collective intelligence
[Music]
basically when when you want to design
autonomous cars or drones that
fly on their own you have to give them
some rules how they should interact with
their environment
and with other drones or uh with whom
it's a
experience in their environment and
exploring these rules
is very uh very hard if you don't have a
base
line where to refer to and that's how we
can use
our fish our robotic fish we can test
rules that would apply also to
autonomous cars
here with the robot and we can see
whether these rules then really work
in a more or less um real environment
many things are simulated in the
computer how things should work in
these kind of autonomous cars or drones
but you always have to go the
next step into the real world because
there could be a
real world gap as it is called so in the
computer everything works fine but then
yeah the computer don't has walls the
computer don't have any friction or
uh something like this the computer
don't have uh yeah
battery limits that uh yeah may be not
um linear and so you really have to try
out your rules
that you want to apply in a real world
scenario and that is
how we can also use the robot
[Applause]
the advantage to do something like this
in berlin is that berlin has so many
universities and so many good
researchers that are all
located here in berlin so as i said
before
this project is a yeah it's a teamwork
of researchers from the technical
university from the free university from
the humboldt university
from several leibniz institutes and
yeah berlin is a perfect place to have
this kind of collaboration because there
are so many scientists
from so many different fields that you
really can bring together
them in in one room and then talk
together
to them talk with them talk about ideas
and then
yeah bring these ideas to the road which
the robot is a perfect example
[Music]
i think my yeah my personal fascinating
uh fascination
uh derived from very early childhood
experiences where i think
an uncle of mine uh yeah gave me
some fish i don't remember the species
in a small bowl and i had them
for a long time and then yeah
as a teenager i had a lot of tanks in my
uh my room and
uh yeah i think my parents weren't so
happy about that
but finally yeah it played out and i i
found a job
really looking at fish so yeah in the
end it paid off and i
really uh yeah work or have fish
fascinated by fish for yeah since mostly
all of my life
[Music]
you